[Music]
i have a really really great question
and i'm glad both of you guys are here
to answer this
um i
i yeah i know you guys can have good
ones um this is this is my question i
have for you guys what is the worst
thing you've ever read about yourself on
the internet
where do i even begin bro like what is
the thing that really affected you not
worse as in like what the public would
see is worse but for you personally
about yourself that actually hits you
because a lot of people you know they'll
type whatever the [ __ ] they want and
sometimes they assume it's not even
going to touch you but like some stuff
actually does hurt you huh
you go first
that's a really good question
something that's touched me in the world
it's gonna sound this is gonna sound
interesting i don't wanna say
interesting but i guess just it's it's
not an answer that's probably heard a
lot but i personally when people random
people say [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] but what bothers me
the most which like emotionally is when
other indian people are like yo why
aren't you in more [ __ ]
and that i'm like
are they saying that to support or are
they saying that as a disapproving
indian fighter i i don't i think it's i
don't think they mean harm by it i don't
i don't think they ever mean harm hey
how come you're not able you should do
this and you should do that you should
do this right and it's like not that
they're angry but it's like yo dude come
on like come on like represent us better
and then my flip side what's going
through my head is like have you watched
the last thing 10 things that i've done
oh yeah you know what i mean like what
if they're not even watching it in the
first place
so the the thing that frustrates me a
lot is when they're like oh we want more
uh you know asian representation or
south asian representation specifically
and i go well then are you supporting
the artwork that i'm doing are you
supporting the greater movement towards
you know more asians but they're like
you're not saying cheating yeah
they're like how come you weren't saying
they want you to just magically appear
in all the things they're already
currently watching yeah exactly and i'm
like that's not how come you weren't
kumar yeah
and i'm like why aren't you the [ __ ]
you know president of the united stand
i've been chatting with vice president
kamala harris this entire goddamn
[ __ ]
that's always confused me though so that
that's the only time that it's really
kind of emotionally
yeah i'm like
that hits you that hits me
like why like what does it makes you
feel like [ __ ] maybe i should be doing
more so it's both right and also it's
like people just don't see
the other side of the table the
auditions the [ __ ] politics
like i'm just looking at my email right
now i have an 11-page audition on monday
and like so i have to think about it and
i have to read the script and then i got
to memorize it right and memorize 11
pages yeah holy [ __ ] and so it's prone
to a lot of brain power but what i'm
saying is like that's my job right and
that's i'm going to do everything
it's like a little kid like reacting
when i have to do book reports dude
come on bro you got an audition this
weekend you how many pages was it was
you got an audition yeah no it's a
[ __ ] uh it was a a
sign of the stars oh there you go what's
the sign of a star targeted
advertisement
no no because yesterday i was instagram
i was laying in bed on instagram right
and on the explore page i was just
looking at explore pixie and then there
was an open casting call that said
sponsored chinese dudes
they need a taiwanese guy and i'm like
oh oh [ __ ] i have an audition for you in
a long time so i click on it and then
i'm like oh man i wish i had a actor
friend that could help me and i'm like
wait tesh is here tomorrow so i idea you
dm me last night later you're an actor
friend you have so many actors i was
actually i'm very honored that he yeah
so i damned and i'm like hey what do you
think like what's the process like i
know the auditioning process way
different now you do a lot of self tapes
all that kind of stuff so he helped me
this morning and then i was just like
dude all these things that are aligning
i'm like i think it's a sign i should
probably do it so i was like do it dude
you'll finally be a part of the cast of
genghis khan now that's cool
marco polo got canceled like 10 years
ago dude i auditioned for
marco polo somebody they had an indian
character on the show went to an older
guy but i remember auditioning it was
one of my first auditions in l.a oh cool
wow
but yeah that that probably hurts me the
most and then the one thing on like the
business side that i'm always like is
when you i send something in
or i get feedback and they're just like
yeah we don't i just i didn't get it
like i just didn't i didn't get it
i'm like
yeah because the story is about an
indian-american kid but you're telling
this to like a jewish kid or something
yeah
and i'm like of course
you didn't get it it has nothing to do
with you you're supposed to oh but
there's no curry yeah and i'm like
you're supposed to empathize with me
have you ever got an email back like
tesh uh we were hoping a little bit of
more magic carpet stuff but we didn't
get it yet i didn't get it like i didn't
get it there was no there was no lamp
uh there was no sand there was no
indescribability i didn't really i
didn't see any aunties with mid-drift so
like i didn't
like i was sick
there was no song and dance there's no
talking monkey i don't get it we had
this action comedy script that we wrote
where uh this guy he's like a
disgruntled retired fighter at the end
um he comes back and he's kind of like
gets walked all over by his son walked
all over by his ex-wife
at the end he finally mans up right so
the final scene for this guy he comes
back and he goes in the house and his
wife his ex-wife is getting game by all
of these dudes big orgies
steve wrote it yeah
no but it's actually very heartfelt
the gangbang is very so the x y
everyone's in love with each other so
the ex-wife um is getting game bang just
like usual like you you'll see like
dudes coming in all the time he's trying
to have breakfast so it's a gang bang or
is it a train it's very different right
it's an orgy it's an archer it's an orgy
but he comes back and he wants to train
he wants to take his life back so he
fights them and there's all these dudes
and he's beating the imaginary
entertainment
he sent this to the production company
to see if we can get it funded the guy
who's the guy that writes scripts you
know that they'll write like is this
like four quadrant or is this whatever
roger ebert no no no no the guy
yeah yeah yes like he's the guy there's
someone who'll do like script analysis
yeah he's the guy that goes okay this
goes on the producer's table or this
goes yeah like give it a so he gave it a
great and he goes he's using all these
[ __ ] big ass nerdy ass geeky ass
words and then so he's like oh i don't
get it whatever i'm of course you know
because you're a [ __ ] geek and it's
all like man now we got this genius
script that we can't even shoot
but i know how you feel but it's
that's what hurts me same thing same
thing
i can relate what can you do and this is
a very asian thing nothing you do is
good enough just nothing you do is good
though yes you guys could have saw this
it was genius
tweed do you have a time that you
remember that um it really it's not like
a time it's just kind of like in general
but it will be from people that don't
really watch my content and they'll just
see me and they'll say things like oh
why don't you want to be your own race
like why don't what right like but
you're born in vietnam what are you
doing
you can't be anymore are you shang tsung
just changing people right i'm like
i'm vietnamese as [ __ ] my content is
vietnamese as [ __ ] like i don't know
where this is coming from but they see
me they see that i have a boyfriend
that's not vietnamese and they're like
oh you want to be black
or you want to be this or you want to be
i get that too because it's like you're
going to like exactly so you want to be
white right like every single pop-up
i've done i've done vietnamese food yeah
you know so it's just like everything
that i've done it's just been vietnamese
as [ __ ] and they're crazy and your
name's toy it's not toy nica but also
how do you be more vietnamese what does
that even mean we're having they want
they want her to go hey mother everybody
we're going to make the egg roll today
and then they're like that seed that's
that's what we want
that's what they want
they always want the version that's
going to make them safe right and we
represent i want to say a new age
of asian americans who are
pushing the boundaries of what is
appropriate for our asian cultures so
like being in the arts or you know being
in the culinary arts or anything that's
just outside of the box is frowned upon
exactly and so then you know also too
the degenerate asians have never had
representation and we are that safe
space [ __ ] [ __ ] we're asian
degenerate degenerate asians
or
yeah maybe maybe okay but then the rest
of us come on right here but i'm here to
bridge the gap i'm a dj you're asking if
we ever had representation and agents
not stuff
not from a traditional talent point of
view and i think it's because they're
ashamed of us
even asians i feel like don't [ __ ]
want us to represent yeah no but like
that's crazy because then you could be
like oh well i wanted to do a movie and
in this movie i'm going to stick my dick
in an apple pie and try to [ __ ] it yeah
that's representation that's pretty good
and then everyone's like this ends up
becoming one of the most iconic movies
right right and so if you want to do a
gangbang where this guy saves his
wife naked dudes
was there any was there any dick
technique did you have like a special he
uses his dick like a pogo stick and like
no he just beats up all these dudes it's
a really good because he's tired of them
[ __ ] his wife and it's kind of like
that one movie remember uh with the dude
with the girl in a roller skates boogie
nights yeah you know how that that guy i
was just gonna i was wondering what
movie you're gonna relate to
the gang the naked guy
he keeps catching his wife [ __ ] and
he's a he's he's a weak guy wait which
way are you talking boogie nights no i
know
predator okay predator [ __ ]
terminator right oh my god no so so so
you know in that scene
he's a weakness
joy luck club that's what it was joy
luck club toilet it's shrek all right
shut the [ __ ] up today's video is
brought to you by upstar if you got
multiple credit card balances each month
and are getting by just paying the
minimums barely making a dent into your
credit card debt it could be pretty dang
discouraging upstart can help you pay
off your existing debt quickly so you
can feel like you're finally getting
ahead whether you're paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
that you're more than just your credit
score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five-minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 all the way
up to 50 000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record don't forget to use the
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you well every
time you come in with a movie they're
like oh yeah we have the joy luck club
i'm like that movie was made 30 years
ago and it's just chinese people use
that as a team
and it's like chinese people from like
san francisco or some [ __ ] like i don't
even know that life you know
anyways so so all right [ __ ] it
you know in that scene
his wife is always getting [ __ ] right
he keeps cat and he can't take it
anymore
right
same concept he's eating [ __ ]
breakfast with his son and his wife is
getting [ __ ] in the other room all
this stuff and at the end he's like i
can't take this anymore and he beats the
[ __ ] out of all the dudes no but this is
like in eastern promises
except it's in the russian you've seen
that movie the movie with the vigo
morton yeah there's a there's a famous
fight scene where they're in a russian
bath house and everyone is naked and
they just fight each other that's cool
because they were like they fight
they were like oh we can hit him
what are the weapons it's a fist fight
if i remember correctly yeah and towels
a lot of towels
being used
the funny thing about those
representation had a russian bathtub
dude have you ever gotten in the face of
dildo it hurts honestly they're pretty
thick they're really thick i got hit by
the giant uh
with those [ __ ] gummy worms you know
what i'm talking about
it kind of resembles it
i was whacking everybody with it
you could probably kill somebody with
that it [ __ ] hurts
does it hurt as bad as being told you're
not vietnamese enough
i'm not vietnamese enough
well i guess if they're telling you that
yeah yeah so how do you respond to that
i don't i don't i just see it but i'm
just like dang really but i know that
it's from people that don't watch me so
of course well see that's that's good
that you see it that way which is
totally correct like these aren't actual
criticisms with any grounds exactly but
have you neither of you guys have ever
read something about yourself um
kind of like jumping off on the
representation thing where i felt like
what the [ __ ] is um yeah like you know
asian americans or whatever they they
they come at me and they're like dude
you are a role model you got to
represent asians this and this and i'm
like dude i talk about getting rim jobs
on [ __ ] camera how the [ __ ] was i
even a role model to begin with
you're a hero
and i'm like am i supposed to be the
pillar of japanese america [ __ ] no dude
that's never who i was that's like well
this is this goes the thing is like
because we're minorities we have to
represent the best of the best i don't
want the burden but why is it like
japanese prime minister
how come when anthony does it you guys
get most [ __ ]
because his son i like prime minister
prime ribbister prime minister
prime remus
prime prime minister
why my girlfriend should certain
cultures
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] that's fire that's so dope it's
a good one this is the freak this is
going on youtube right it's a free
country it's normal bro you're making
room jobs for men okay what i'm fighting
for i'm like the new normal okay i'm not
ashamed that i have a hidden agenda
throughout all of this trombone that's
my campaign 2022.
[Laughter]
just be careful make everything rusty
again i'll vote for you but you know
that's the thing it's like i'm here to
do comedy bro like that's it [ __ ] it
like why do i gotta have to carry all of
asia on my back and then be like and
that and i
i was a [ __ ] i was a [ __ ] dumbass
to begin with i never was a great role
model like in that sense right so then
now you want me to [ __ ] clean up and
act a certain way i'm like did you even
watch my content for the last 15 years
i've been dumb on camera
all of a sudden you want me to be pro
premium proper like what it's weird i
don't know it's just weird but that is
the burden that minorities have is like
you're representing you represent
millions of people yeah yeah because
there's not enough representation this
is when we're talking earlier definition
of please
focuses on a bengali indian family and
that's a certain region like punjabi or
gujarati or thermal right and so you
have very specific things the food the
culture the customs
and it's not a monolith and we don't
represent monoliths of our own culture
we represent certain sectors and
that's what's so frustrating is because
a lot of people from other cultures get
the opportunity to do their dumb stupid
movie and they can then do a serious
drama but if i do one or the other it's
like no no they're stuck there yeah
i'm like what are you talking about like
jim carrey can be dumb and dumber and
then he can go do you know a very
serious role yeah
this might be a little bit
going off topic but isn't it weird how
all of this right here is considered one
culture in america this is all asian
america right right so it's like dude
how this is billions of people back in
asia with different cultures there's a
lot of wars right between these cities
and then they'll argue that look india
is the only subcontinent okay so i don't
know like its own thing you guys i don't
know what you guys are first of all you
were all part of india at one point
india's india for sure the weirdest
thing also is that most of the people
who are saying these things like you
said they don't watch all your [ __ ] but
they're also usually not from the same
generation as you yeah so it's even
bigger of a gap for them to fully
understand where you're coming from
because you also have to explain that
like not everybody is criticizing you as
your age
well people will watch this and be like
you guys aren't diverse enough and i'm
like what are you talking about this
indian man [ __ ] chinese man and
[ __ ] singaporean
we represent three billion people on
this planet
will you now add another billion we're
too diverse
honestly or if we like to have fun and
make fun of like anthony or anyone else
right and everyone they're like oh you
guys got to stop doing that but they're
like dude this is our real friendship
yeah so because of the generation gap i
don't know if that's they don't people
don't know they don't make friends like
that anymore but you know like from our
generation we're just [ __ ] around
having a good time and people don't
understand that part of it well yeah
nobody verbally roughhouses anymore yeah
i remember roasted anthony and that's
when i was like you're a part of us now
you get it you get it you get it i don't
know i probably said something no she
said something about it she was like
this [ __ ]
and
it wasn't even like in the conversation
like on the side hey you're a [ __ ]
cameras were off yeah i wasn't even
rolling she was whispering this year
she's like yeah
off camera she's like [ __ ] you anthony
just under the table
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
napkin
look at this gangbang script
that's why toy is cool man that is why
toy is cool
i want to know more about this gangbang
movie it's good it's a martial art movie
can i be in it can i be in it oh hell
yeah dude 30 seconds what's the martial
art exactly second all right so
basically uh like a traditional martial
artist right
he he you know he goes off to uh mma
competition and he fights the world's
greatest fighter which is like mcgregor
or whoever and all he has to do is last
30 seconds so he could win money to save
the rec center basically
the budget all went to getting mcgregor
on
and the gang bank
sees a lot of production the insurance
for that is a lot right
it's a hard one let's do it let's just
do it man you want to you want to be a
part of it man let's do it i'm gonna
send you the script yeah
you have a finished script that's the
feat man i can't wait for you to read
this and go this is a masterpiece how
many pages is it uh i feel like 85.90 oh
it's a feature bro oh that's for real we
have five features written it went
nowhere and we have a actual like press
press kit
oh you have the epk ready to go we have
it yeah i'll send it to you maybe your
photos and all maybe you know yeah we
did like a mock photo shoot what could
look like throw it in your stack when
you do a picture when i do my picture
i'll be like oh so i have this idea so
here's i'm not gonna pitch you in the
movie but i'm gonna put you on one scene
and tell me if you guys are in
gangbang naked cockfight yep is there
yes
what am i well yeah how would you say i
want the creators one of my favorite
scenes is so this guy he's like a
disgruntled uh so how the story goes is
it's it's two leads right the main lead
that's the trainer
he he knocked someone out and he killed
them and he's so he feels so bad it's
his backstory he decides to never ever
fight again because his hands are too
lethal
brother i want you to paint this as
specifically as possible does he kill
him with one strike one strike one side
of my head so the guy that um that has
everything together in the ring of
course has everything in shambles
outside of the ring of course the
symbolism horrible horrible relationship
with this alcoholic yeah his kid calls
him all these slurs that you really
can't say on the show like this he's a
cod player
he's on xbox yeah you know he's all you
need to say but there's this my favorite
scene is there's a scene where he's
having like cereal with his kid he's
finally having a heart-to-heart and in
the back you just hear oh harder harder
and harder all right that wouldn't come
because his ex-wife is having sex he's
getting [ __ ] bone
because she's a nympho yeah
but it's a very it's like it's heartfelt
mix with step brothers with a little bit
of likes jojo rabbit stephen
jojo i would watch that yeah i want to
watch it all of these parts that you've
mixed have you not put a single porno
it's this mix of this because of this
no no it's actually very deep it's a
relationship so you never actually see
the gang bang you see it okay so you see
a highlight okay it's the oh it
is i have some notes
i have some notes i'll say give us one
note
and the main character that played by
joe
he is just one of those guys talking
[ __ ] at the bar right and then he's like
what the [ __ ] dude i'll get paid 10
million to get knocked out by this guy
and of course some guys recording him on
the side and then that's the clip that
goes viral so the conor mcgregor of this
world goes what the [ __ ] there's a guy
that's talking [ __ ] and he's trying to
clean out his record so he actually goes
and tries to find him to challenge him
to a fight can he last 30 seconds and
that's when this guy goes to a taekwondo
school to learn how to fight and you see
people kick apples off people's heads
and then he and then people are like
you're gonna die
from this guy the guy who vowed to never
fight ever again the guy who killed
somebody yes but then they become good
friends and then yeah yeah so it's
heartfelt it's very heartfelt it's more
about friendship yeah dude
it's like a school of rock you know but
with just gangbangs in it well i was
gonna ask because i got totally
distracted and forgot the whole
character motivation is the mom
a prostitute or an s she's horny she's
just horny she just loves to [ __ ] now
she's free so she's free so she's ex
ex-wife [ __ ] liberated yeah yeah but
then he's also a loser so he needs to go
over there so to see to quickly and you
guys obviously she's trying to [ __ ] her
way back into finding the man that this
guy used to be right like a superstar so
i thought you should make her a sex
worker because he's down and out and
she's doing this to protect her family
right so her motivation is also
protected family first but from everyone
outside is like yo you're being a [ __ ]
and what she's saying is no
i'm fighting for my family uh to pay the
bills that way the abilities are
divisive right you get writing credit
there you go just like that that's legit
think
i think it's a stronger character
motivation yep
then that way the husband and the wife
can have a conflict of like i want i can
make money and she's like but you're not
yeah which then this is karate which is
then forces them to be like i'm gonna go
fight conor mcgregor you're a good
script doctor yeah you got to make the
emotional connection
when can we expect this to be under
production whenever he can get her
funded by someone cool because everyone
hates us yep
i would fund it myself but i put all my
money in crypto and it went didn't go
anywhere just started go fund me for the
movie i put all my money in anti-indian
cream
just what did i call it unfair and
disgruntled
you